it's always on target it's a walk but a
beautiful rotation on the stroke there
from Alexander Walker coach is a friend
the John Beilein says look I've got this
kid transfers to Michigan ends up
playing in a national championship game
on Big Ten title teams our second game
here on the Thomas & Mack Center today
with teams planned for a spot in the
semifinals tomorrow on ESPN through the
championship Monday night and Nikhil
Alexander Walker is a nice day continues
he's got 10 how could you go 13 miles
and then do it again three nights later
or whatever you do man done the
Robinsons been good he fit into the Big
Ten there was no learning curve for him
he was just really good working on
defending working on rebounding and
there's that kid again doing things
Alexander Walker flash she's got 20 in
trailing only Robinson has caught the 25
year old from Trenton New Jersey when I
forget a few years ago holy cow Jackson
Hayes where is his head on this play he
just rained it full speed the bucket on
one end and fearless attacking the glass
there's a lot to like about Jackson
Hayes man he is playing God Alexander
Walker's pass was almost too good for
Big D Williams stop instant game high 26
points his pick pocketed by the former
Virginia Tech Hokies soars to the basket
and scores off the window they not feed
you but it will sustain it seal yes it
gets a lot of places Williams play good
defense on the left block against me
cook
use the screen and has it taken away by
Alexander Walker what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with wheats report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content